i just want to start with uh i've seen
the first three episodes of season two i
wish i had access to more you guys know
i'm a big fan of this uh of this series
uh i am curious which of you for each of
you which of your friends and family are
the most excited that you're part of
this series and do they constantly text
you asking for spoilers
i try to give my husband um a script
once and he fell asleep after two
pages
so he's not that invested i would say i
don't know if i have any other family
members
being super probably my brother i'm
having to constantly fight my agent to
stop calling and asking questions which
couldn't you know
get me in trouble essentially he's
always asking for like links to the show
or you know oh have you got access to
the next script and i'm like please i
can't i can't share this with you i know
that you've given me this opportunity
but like
i can't do this this is a weird
relationship now so uh yeah
my okay she hasn't seen the show because
she's only like five but she's seen like
trailers my niece ali
is like
obsessed with like the mother character
she thinks she's like this
like super badass character but i can't
explain why like what what the show was
about but she's like she she asked the
most amount of questions about like wait
a minute she's five
but she'd be like wait a minute how does
she fly and what's that coming over eyes
so she's kind of asking the questions
that i could should be asking as an
actor which is quite actually screaming
all the time yeah like how did she do
that
why aren't the kids afraid of her and
they're like that's a good question it's
like why why are you super friends with
her like i don't know
i gotta get off my back you know the
thing about the planet you guys are on
it's sort of like a haunted house and
that there's just things hidden like
things that come up um because it's like
a haunted house and i'm just curious how
much has aaron actually told you guys
all the secrets of what's going on and
how much is it sort of you finding out
script by script he hasn't
it seems like he tells reporters more
yeah exactly
kind of like the year in advance during
the big lockdown
um and so we all kind of got told
roughly what was going to happen with
our characters in season two but we
didn't know what was happening to the
other characters so when we all
got when we like all arrived in south
africa we just had like half the scripts
then and the latter half were kind of
coming as as we were shooting so we were
all trying to like figure out you know
what was what was everyone going to be
up to so there was a lot of
that going on everyone everyone knew
their secrets but they didn't know the
full story
to be fair he he's also figuring out
while we go along like he has a
i'm sure he has a great outline of
what's gonna happen but he also needs
the freedom to
sort of
let things
flow
and um
it's a it's a challenge at times to not
know
but it's also a gift in terms of
learning how to let go and trust
your creator
what are you guys actually allowed to
tease about season two what do you want
fans to know oh man it's is if you
thought season one was a wild ride this
is
like
a wild
life
it's a crazy experience man and i think
season two not only does it i feel like
answer
a lot of questions and and thoughts from
season one
but it presents
more but i feel like it also weirdly
arms you with the right
tools in order to answer the questions
as well as they arise i think it's i
think season two is it is on a there's
another league of its own i really do
there's a re like we're introduced to a
heck of a lot more characters that are
amazing amazing actors
and from all over the globe and so with
these new characters more you know
they're put into new
scenarios and relationships form and
ultimately the kids are getting older so
you know they're becoming more involved
in adults problems and
yes
there's a lot there's a lot going on
this season and we're on a completely
different part of the planet that looks
completely different and it's like the
production design is unbelievable so
if you thought you knew what was gonna
happen in season one
just get ready
yeah
yeah and i think we all got so blown
away by the finale last season so
so we're kind of accustomed to what
happens in season two we're like oh okay
well here's another script while
where crazy [ __ ] happens all the time i
guess what's new
on this planet right but there's
definitely the the pace of things it's
um moving rapidly yeah like i said i
cannot wait to see where this all goes
um i gotta stop i'm just gonna say
congrats on being uh in such a kick-ass
series i wish you guys nothing but the
best
thank you steven
thank you
you